well I finally received the results of
my coronavirus test and they were
negative yes that's a relief hooray we
can finally isolate as a family we're
very fortunate that we can keep doing
this show from our private office but a
lot of people aren't so lucky as the
coronavirus forces many businesses to
shut down people everywhere are losing
their jobs or seeing their ours
dramatically scaled back as of March
21st 3.3 million Americans filed for
unemployment the largest number in
history by a wide margin the previous
record was set in 1982 at six hundred
ninety five thousand
four dict by this summer over 14 million
Americans will have lost their jobs it's
a unique situation in past unemployment
crises the government usually tries to
encourage businesses to increase hiring
but this time we actually want people to
stay home to slow the spread of disease
so Congress recently passed a two
trillion dollar stimulus package that
includes a massive expansion of
unemployment insurance to help keep
Americans afloat while we wait out the
storm even if you still have your job
this bill will most likely affect you so
you should know what's in it first free
money if you were a United States
resident with a social security number
not claimed as a dependent and made less
than 75 thousand dollars last year you
will receive a $1,200 check from Uncle
Sam
plus five hundred dollars for each child
you have under 16 the more you made over
75,000 the smaller the check gets and is
totally phased out for people with
incomes greater than 99 thousand but
married filers earning less than a
hundred and fifty thousand together get
the full amount so if Dan makes a
hundred and five thousand and Marsha
makes 40 thousand they still both get
twelve hundred each plus fifteen hundred
for their three kids you do not have to
apply or sign up or do anything at all
to get that money it's a one-time
payment based on your 2019 gross income
and should be arriving in about three
weeks or so by mail or direct deposit if
you already have that set up
the IRS if you haven't filed your 2019
taxes yet they can use your gross income
from your 2018 tax return but if you
still haven't filed that either
you should ASAP or risk not getting your
check and if you happen to make over a
hundred thousand and 2019 but expect to
lose that income this year well
unfortunately you won't qualify sorry
next the bill provides a dramatic
increase in unemployment insurance
traditionally unemployment insurance is
only available to people who lose
full-time w-2 jobs through no fault of
their own it usually lasts about 26
weeks and pays around 45% of lost wages
but this bill expands pretty much all of
that freelancers part-timers gig economy
workers and even people who still have
jobs but had their hours cut can all now
apply for unemployment insurance you're
also eligible if you are about to start
a new job or are too new to a job -
normally qualify for benefits at the
closure of a school or nursing home
means you have to quit your job and stay
home to take care of someone you are
eligible for unemployment insurance
basically if the corona virus pandemic
has severely hampered your ability to
make money you probably qualify for some
kind of benefit how much and for how
long depends on your state in your
previous income level but the federal
government is increasing the duration
across the board by 13 weeks and the
benefit amount by six hundred dollars a
week here in Texas weekly unemployment
benefits are calculated by taking your
highest earning quarter of the last year
and dividing by 25 up to a maximum of
four hundred and fifty four dollars so
Timothy who was making about 30k a year
waiting tables before his restaurant
shuttered would normally be eligible for
$300 a week for 26 weeks now thanks to
this bill he'll be getting in $900 a
week and his benefits will last for 39
weeks you might be thinking wait that's
more than he was making before and while
that's true there is a catch that extra
six hundred bucks a week is only
available for four months and
July 31st so unless Congress extends it
he's only getting $900 for the first 16
weeks since most experts doubt that
either this medical or financial crisis
will be over by then
Timothy is hardly on easy street this
bill isn't a magic wand that will keep
us all afloat in perpetuity it's a
temporary life raft to buy Americans
some time and a way to keep money
flowing through the economy in the short
term there's a lot more in it we haven't
discussed student loan suspensions funds
for health care and expansion of loans
available to small businesses and of
course a five hundred billion dollar
loan package for large businesses and
municipalities we'll be talking about
those things in the weeks to come but
for now if your income has been impacted
by the corona virus pandemic grab
yourself a seat on Uncle Sam's life raft
while there's still room it will give
you some breathing space to take a fresh
look at your finances and plan for what
comes next
and that's our two cents
you
[Music]